المصريون القدماء سجلوا على جدران المعابد
مظاهر من حياتهم اليوميه ومعاركهم
وانتصاراتهم ولكن ماذا عن الحب فكيف كان
الحب عند الفراعنه اغنيه مرود او حبك هي
اول اغنيه رومانسيه باللغه المصريه
القديمه غنتها السوبرانو المصريه العالميه
اميره سليم الفكره الحقيقه موجوده من قبل
موكب الموميات يعني انا ده كان حلم عندي
ان انا اعمل اغاني باللغه المصريه القديمه
من قبل الموكب بسنوات وعملت ابحاث كتير
واخترت اغاني وقصائد كثيره ومنها الاغنيه
اللي انا عملتها ميروت ايك يعني دي كانت
موجوده في الدرج من زمان
[موسيقى]
ايه قصه الاغنيه بقى البرديه بتاعه
الاغنيه كانت موجوده فين وبتكلم عن ايه
اغنيه ميروت ايك بمعنى حبك هي قصيده من
مجموعه قصائد على برديه
دي موجوده في المتحف البريطاني
وهي بتتكلم عن امراه
مفتقده حبيبها وبتفكر فيه لانه بعيد عنها
وهو حوار ما بين رجل وامراه يعني في كذا
قصيده وانا اخترت الجزء الخاص بالمراه
اللي هي بتفكر في حبيبها بحب ومشاعر كثيره
دي برديه مصريه قديمه ومليانه قصائد حب من
الاسره ال18
والفتره في مصر القديمه اللي كان فيها
الادب والشاعر والفنون مزدهره يعني
الاختصار هي
بتفتكر حبيبها
وبتتساءل ليه هو بعيد عنها
وبتتذكر حب ولما بتت حب وقلبها
بينكشف كلميني عن اللغه بتاعه الاغنيه
وازاي قدرتوا انكم
تظبطوا النطق بتاعها الحقيقه ان انا
اشتغلت مع الدكتوره ياسمين الشاذلي بحيث
المصريات على النطق وطريقه القاء ووضعها
في غنائيا كمان يعني طبعا ان احنا نتكلم
اللغه حاجه وان احنا نغنيها بتبقى دايما
حاجه ثانيه لكن طبعا اللغه المصريه
القديمه احنا عارفين ان دايما في جدال وفي
شويه يعني شكوك ازاي بتتنطق بالضبط مئه في
المئه يعني لغايه دلوقتي في الحروف
المتحركه احنا مش متاكدين منها مئه في
المئه لكن متاكدين من الحروف الساكنه اكتر
الفولز فيها صعوبات لغايه دلوقتي ولكن
شامبليون لما فك حجر رشيد وفك رموز
الهيروغليفيه عرفنا نوعا ما اللي هو
المصريه القديمه ازاي
الاقرب شيء للنطق الصحيح بتاعها ايه اللي
عرفتيه من الاغنيه دي عن الحب في هذه
الفتره لا المصريين القدماء كان عندهم
حريه في التعامل مع قصص الحب يعني احنا
عندنا اساطير كثيره طبعا الملوك ادريس
يعني قصه حب كثيره ولكن كمان في الحياه
اليوميه المواطن العادي كان بيعبر عن الحب
المراه كان بتعبر عن الحب بحريه وجمال
ومشاعر تلقائيه وبسيطه جدا بتحسي ايه ردود
افعال الناس دي تاني تجربه بالنسبه لك
للغناء باللغه المصريه القديمه الناس حباه
الرياكشن دايما بيفاجئني يعني انا زي ما
بقول دايما المصريين عندهم القدره انهم
يتذوقوا اي شيء لو اديناهم الفرصه فهم
يعني تقبلوها بفكره انه احنا في تواصل
بيحصل ما بيننا وما بين تاريخ اجدادنا وما
بين الهويه بتاعتنا في كان دايما في كان
دايما بردو شويه ردود فعل من النوع ليه مش
باللغه العربيه ليه ما بتعنيش باللغه
العربيه مع ان دي لغتنا وده حقيقي دي
لغتنا اللي بنكتب بها وبنتكلم بها لكن ده
ما يمنعش ان احنا برضو لغتنا المصريه
القديمه من حقنا ان احنا نحييها مره اخرى